that your word is your bond that you do
what you say you're going to do that
your word is your bond and you do what
you say and keep your promise Melania
Trump ASSA bleep laid your eyes to
convention speech is the gift that keeps
on a giving as a Broadway star Laura
Benanti gives it the parity treatment on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert I
learned fall asleep during my humble
upbringing in the West Philadelphia
thank you on the playground is where I
spend most of my days Colbert is taking
a show alive this week because of the
convention and he tells ET the Trump's
were a big factor in that decision we
want to wait another 24 hours especially
with the Trump campaign because 24 hours
later he's gonna say something totally
different
for four hours he's gonna say I didn't
mean what I said yesterday I don't
remember saying it yesterday so not only
are we going to be live every night I
call no backsies okay oh okay this is no
no no take-backs okay whatever you say
on Monday you have to still mean on
Tuesday